[Applause]
benny needs the moment to take that in
y'all already know what time it is
everybody is getting to the end of their
90 days so it's either i do
or i don't as you can see benny and ari
are officially husband and wife and so
are muhammad and eve
yes
she married him
i couldn't believe it but you know eva's
big on intuition i've always felt very
spiritual so if she feels in her heart
that this is the best decision for her
so be it let the force be with you we're
gonna take a look at the standout
moments from the couple's big days
including moments that made my heart
melt and moments like this
yeah that's muhammad getting jiggy with
it on the dance floor if there was a
video next to the definition of jiggy
this would be it go ahead muhammad
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa before
we get into the wedding you remember
last week the shelties shyda getting
upset after seeing the wedding dress
that below sister made for her for the
first time
how can i get married in this old lady
dress
someone clearly was not
we'll
taking
to find out
it was a prank
another one yes another one
gosh
[Music]
i know you're not in the mood but close
your eyes one more time
okay open it up
[Music]
oh my god
so
yeah i just decided to play a little
joke on you with that one they better be
careful with these pranks because one
day it's going to be something serious
and she's going to think it's a joke you
heard about the boy you cried wolf what
is it with you and a lot of crimes it's
a family trip it's a family trait yes
clearly
speaking of family shite's two younger
sisters are in town for the wedding and
you can tell that they are all related
they're beautiful are y'all feeling
how we feeling you are feeling you
getting married not us her sisters were
only able to make it because they are
studying in new york the rest of shada's
family couldn't make it because they're
back in trinidad and the borders are
closed
by the way
china's sisters don't seem to be huge
fans of blau
actually american men in general i don't
like that print of thing i really don't
my entire family knows about the
pre-nuptial agreement between bilal and
myself
it's not something that they agreed with
per se because back home our prenup is
foreign like that's something we don't
do back home so they are
not it's not sitting well with them i'm
shocked that you end up with an american
because you know
i don't know i talked to one or two my
very limited experience american men and
[Music]
oh very cocky they knew it all oh okay
boy i tell you watching this show you
get to see how people from other
countries really feel about us americans
outside of the opportunities this land
has to offer
it's very humbling
i feel pretty wedding after we're going
to finish married or going and
performing kanye west school digger
no it's not
since she wanted
if her sister did that i am not going to
lie i would love to see it
if you ain't no punk
we want prenup we want prina yes you
better not play no gold digging sorry
for me yeah
that is such a little sister thing to do
i'm a little sister so i get it but yeah
no she shouldn't do that it would have
everyone else at the wedding in their
business kanye west go digger why would
they play that
today is the big day all right next week
it looks like we will be able to see
shaida and bilal say i do
i can't wait
also i have to shout out kander real
quick after last week's episode they
said below's mom needs to be placed on
the 90-day mvp wall for being a voice of
reason in this 90-day world where they
don't come around often but when it
comes to trust what does trust really
mean it means different things to
different people
i agree kander
she was speaking truth let's go ahead
and put her on there yep
she looks like she belongs thanks for
that
i love that wall
all right
let's get into benny and ari's wedding
now i know that these two officially
tying the knot is something i had to
cover because they're one of the more
popular 90-day couples but am i the only
one who feels like they've already been
married so much so that during my
interview with them benny mistakenly
kept calling ari his wife because you
know more than likely during the
interview they were already married but
couldn't tell us
and each time he said it
i didn't flinch until ari called it out
you know she's she's my wife why you
throw my wife just like that
being always like white even from when
the first time we were together because
of ethiopia like if you live together
and you have a baby you're really
what's so interesting though when you
prefer to have your fiance she tried to
clean it up but
yeah am i alone in that
it just feels like it's been a journey
oh they're out
at the top of the episode benny and ari
are preparing for their wedding which is
hours away
ari is at her sisters while benny is at
their house giving ari's dad a haircut
and avi who was so freaking cute
tries to help
okay no no no no no it's yours your
brush yourself
how about you you're here
yeah
that's very good
look benny gave avi the same haircut
that he has
they're both rocking mohawks for the
wedding adorable i'm so happy i'm free
i'm smiling
thanks to god
ari's dad goes on to help binium get
ready for his big day
meanwhile
after having serious doubts about their
long-term compatibility
ari says she's excited now about
marrying binyam but what she's not
really feeling is the fact that his
sisters are going to be there virtually
at first i really didn't like the idea
of wishing me me attending the wedding
even virtually because benny sisters
have not treated me well over the years
particularly right before we left they
threw wine in my face oh we remember
i actually did invite them after i had a
change of heart
because it's gonna make vinnie happy and
i really love him you know yeah that's
evident when it comes to binyam's
sisters ari does a great job with
putting her pride to the side for the
sake of peace
kudos to you girl because
who am i kidding i would probably do the
same thing with my nice self i'm so nice
sometimes i'm too nice okay
but that's beside the point let's get
into the wedding dress reveal my
favorite part
[Music]
wow you look like a princess a princess
statue
she looks like a statue you would see at
madame tusso or something
oh wait you have to see the shoes look
at those glitter sneakers
interesting choice i'm here for it
though she looks beautiful
okay let's fast forward to the ceremony
which by the way they chose to have a
jewish wedding because ari who was
jewish compromised and allowed avi to
have a christian baptism back in
ethiopia because that's what binium
wanted
[Music]
here comes the bride
when i say ari smiling when you look at
me i love her so much she is my angel
like god he gave it to me this beautiful
family
wow
oh you look really nice
benny and ari start to say their vows
but i was distracted by this one why is
avi so cute look at his little lip just
when i lost my first
relationship with my family and ari
should find me like in the streets
she gave it to me hearts she gave it to
me love and then she give it to me like
beautiful family now
i'm so excited for everything
i remember the day that i met you
when you were walking down the street
somehow i got you to stop and talk to me
is bingham trying to hold back to yours
when you're walking down the street
somehow i got you to stop and talk to me
oh he is
and at that time i never thought that
one day we would live in new jersey and
we get married in a temple
you were a great father to avi
and i love you so so so so much
they carry on with jewish tradition and
binium solidifies the marriage by
breaking the glass but then he tries to
pick it up which is actually so
endearing but ari quickly told him to
put it down well don't forget about me
take care of the glass
just kiss your wife
it's like
friends and family honored witnesses it
is my pleasure to present for the first
time as a married couple
[Applause]
we don't know what the future holds but
i definitely think that this family is
going to have a lot more adventures in
the future
[Music]
love you too
wake me up and tell me
oh congrats y'all congrats
let's quickly touch on the wedding i
didn't see coming with eve and muhammad
ta-da he literally like re-proposed to
me again last episode muhammad proposed
to eve for a second time following a
chat with his mom where she told him to
stop judging eve
now eve has decided to move forward with
the marriage despite her doubts that he
will accept her for who she is
and despite the fact that he called her
a sponsor instead of his fiancee and
threatened to return to egypt if they
didn't get married asap because he's
ready to work
if i'm not allowed to work in this
country i will okay so it's all about
asia
i don't think that eve should marry him
and i want her to know that i'm here if
she changes her mind
i know last night he proposed again and
it was a beautiful thing but that's just
like when you get in a fight and someone
brings you roses or a beautiful diamond
ring it's not just that i mean we had a
conversation and you know it's just
we're back at the place that we've
like pretty much been like him being
lovey and romantic and
all that my friends are pretty intuitive
so
i take my friend's concerns seriously
because i want to feel comfortable about
the decision i'm making for the rest of
my life yeah i'm with eve's friends
she's such a good woman she's a
dedicated mom she has a loving heart
she's a hard worker
in my opinion she deserves better but
her friends and i and some of you can
think that all day
it all boils down to what she believes
and for those of you out there who may
be wondering
why is she choosing such a difficult
path or if she's so intuitive why hasn't
her intuition stopped her from moving
forward with muhammad here's something
she told me during our chat that might
give reason to that
she subscribes to the spiritual concept
called twin flames
i'll let her explain we feel like we
have a twin flame connection which he
doesn't usually use that terminology but
i think so and i think that that we are
the epitome of that cultural difference
age difference distance
and you know this union is it's a very
like amazing like kind of bond but also
it's difficult
because it's challenging your souls to
basically like grow
so sometimes you mirror each other or
sometimes you push each other's buttons
and i'm like all right
you know so i've always wanted that in
my life i've always wanted somebody who
actually makes me broke yeah for those
of you who raise the intuition question
that's the best i can give you right now
all right fast forward to the day of the
wedding i would rather have a muslim
ceremony if i can
but my call with my mom was one of the
reasons why i
i can understand that
i am here in the us and eve is an
american
and it's her day did you know that
you're suit you match me homie oh oh my
gosh child
you look so adorable you bring tears to
my eyes you look so handsome yeah
you are oh i love seeing those moments
with her son she lights up speaking of
lighting up eve glows as she walks down
the aisle in her dress and if you notice
her dress is not modest but muhammad is
all smiles he doesn't complain and you
can see her son theron was not feeling
that suit anymore he took it off it is
what it is children have their like time
limits and patience and
with autism sometimes children have less
patience so that's what he ended up
wearing which was just fine
overall it was a touching ceremony a
stranger would never think they just
went through everything they went
through muhammad even cried
[Music]
and now by the power vested in me by the
state of new mexico and spirits
i now pronounce you husband and wife
muhammad you may kiss your bride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this moment
i was waiting for this moment for so
freaking long
yeah so you can
work okay let me stop
let's try to keep it positive here i
like eve no shade muhammad no shade
a little a little
anywho congrats to the happy couple i
guess
and muhammad and that dance move
it just makes me think of things i don't
want to imagine
okay well eve tells the cameras that so
far so good muhammad has been living up
to his promise of accepting her for who
she is
he's been doing things he wouldn't
usually do with her like going to breath
work classes
look at her friend she is really into it
breath work is amazing by the way lots
of benefits
look into it
i decided to be more open because i
realized that if i don't compromise i
will lose eve forever
well we'll see on the tell-all how
things are currently between them if
it's actually working out until then
next week it looks like on top of shaida
and balau getting married we'll see kobe
and emily tie the knot as well as jabrie
and miona
unhappy muna on her wedding day you
don't want to see that no sometimes you
don't get everything you want
i know exactly how i want my wedding to
look like so don't try to ruin my
wedding
i'm also not sure what's going to happen
between taiz and patrick she's been
having major doubts about marrying ken
and when i say major doubts i mean
you can tell deep down she doesn't
really want to
all right 90 day fans fam a lot is
happening but don't worry just make sure
you stick with e.t because we are
covering it all i will see you next time
[Music]
you